Even really simple experiments can sometimes teach you
interesting things and then expected things.
Especially if you look at the temperatures,
what we're going to do is to show you two different experiments.
The first one is pouring sulfuric acid into water.
A thermal imaging camera cannot penetrate water and it cannot penetrate
glass. So we've done the experiment in a plastic beaker.
So you can see through the beaker and see the inside surface of the
water. Now, the acid is much denser than water,
so it sinks to the bottom,
but then the water begins to dilute the acid and the acid
interacts with the water and generates heat.
The interaction is the water molecules interacting
with the H class irons and the SL four, two minus ions.
So the Catalans and the unknowns from the acid,
and since the acid we're pouring in already has some water.
There will be a degree of ionization. And when you diluted,
it will ionize more and there's more water that can solve it.
That's interact with each of the aims.
So if you watch the first thing that's interesting is that the acid layer
gets really hot. But the next thing that's interesting is that, you know,
that hot things rise,
but the acid layer stays hot and the water on top stays relatively
cold.
And the reason for this is that the acid is far denser
than the water. So even with the heating,
it's not light enough to convict up.
And so what you have to do is to stir the acid with the rod,
and then it starts mixing things up.
I was quite surprised by the lack of convection,
but it really demonstrates how important it is to start a reaction
mixture,
okay, stir it. And we're doing some reaction each time you pulled in the acid,
you pour it in slightly differently.
And each time you might get a slightly different result.
So if you want to make a really reproducible experiment,
you need to stir it hard all the time. The obvious next step.
And our second experiment is to see what happens.
If you dissolve an alkaline metal hydroxide in water,
these hydroxides are solids room temperature,
and they are sold as pellets, rather like small beads.
And when you tip these beads into water,
they sink to the bottom and then the water begins to dissolve the pellets.
Now you've got to understand that the solid consists
of metal and metal plus and minus,
and there's a whole array of these, not just two irons and the irons,
because the metal plus is attracted to a minus require energy
to separate them. And that energy has to be put in.
However, because these irons are small,
they interact with the water and the water molecules interacting
with both the positive ions and the negative ions give out heat.
In the case of alkaline metal,
hydroxides the energy that you get from the water.
Interacting with the ions is more than the energy.
Then you need to pull those irons apart.
So overall desolving hydroxides generates heat.
So if we look those pellets at the bottom of the beaker start
glowing, quite hot,
and the solution just above it starts to glue hot,
but just like the acid, that solution is very dense,
far denser than ordinary water.
So it doesn't shoot up towards the surface,
but that concentrated layer gets hotter and hotter.
And you have to be quite careful because you can generate a lot of
heat without realizing it just as before. If you stir it,
you can get that heat to go up into the bulk of the solution.
But unlike the acid, because the pellets are solid,
they stay at the bottom of the beaker.
So you keep on generating the heat at the bottom of the beaker,
but very slowly you can see the heat spreading.
If I'd been asked beforehand what would happen with the temperature in these two
and how they would behave. If I thought a long time, I might have guessed,
but even to me, it was quite a surprise to see this in reality, yeah.
Process that's generating the heat is fundamentally the same.
In both cases, this is water molecules,
interacting with positive and negative ions.
The way they interact is very slightly different because in one case you have a
metal lion that is positive. In the other case,
you have an H plus sign of proton, which is very,
very much smaller because H plus doesn't have any electrons around it.
So the quantum mechanics of the interaction is slightly different,
but on a more global scale, the mechanism is pretty similar.
So what the take home message is is that both acids and
alkalize dissolve in water, generating heat and very dense.
Special,
thanks to Google's making and science team for helping out with this series of
thermal imaging videos to see more films they've helped make with various
creators across YouTube,
check out the link on the screen or in the video description. And likewise,
there are more links if you'd like to see films made by us here at periodic
videos over the years,
including videos on each and every element on the periodic.